90 60 90 les mensurations idéales
regardez mes mensurations honte et vous
lui parce que je suis devenue une femme
les formes se sont développés parce que
j'ai fait plus ou moins de sport j'ai
mangé plus ou moins ceux de ma katia ou
de quelques règles plus récemment il
faut vivre avec son temps et puis il y a
eu des années 80 j'ai une dizaine
d'années je rentre à l'île de la réunion
pour habiter avec mes parents j'adore le
beurre sous mac os et mon oncle
m'appelle boboul mais moi je ne peux
déjà m'empêcher de faire le parallèle
avec cette grosse vache qui se baladent
joyeusement au pied du mont saint michel
vous savez cette vache qui trône sur le
couvercle de la fameuse boîte de beurre
et puis viennent les années 90 j'ai une
vingtaine d'années j'habite à toulouse
où je poursuis mes études
et puis quand j'ai un peu de vague à
l'âme je me jette dans la boîte de ta
katyn cette fois-ci vie en un clin
d'oeil
je me retrouve sur mon île natale mais
je ne regarde plus dans un miroir et
puis arrive l'an 2000 j'ai une trentaine
d'années je suis à nouveau à l'île de la
réunion et j'ai perdu tous les kilos
superflus s'asseoir voilà toute ma vie
j'ai combattu mais qu'ils louent j'ai
combattu longuement vous savez mes dames
n'acceptez pas que l'on définisse votre
beauté 90 60 90
c'est sûr ce sont des chiffres qui me
faisait rêver quand j'étais jeune
me font toujours rêver 1,90 g de
chocolat déguster en 60 minutes chrono
pour les 4-10 philo voyez on peut tout
faire dire aux chiffres
donc on peut tout faire dire aussi
voilà et puis moi depuis que j'ai
commencé dans ma vie professionnelle
j'ai essayé de claire je pensais que les
futurs patrons potentiels préfèrent
aimer mensurations plutôt que mes
compétences
fallait-il vraiment manqué vraiment
beaucoup de confiance en soi pour croire
cela quoique il ya des patrons c'était
le cas mais ça c'est une autre histoire
l'histoire dont il s'agit aujourd'hui ne
commence pas à l'île de la réunion
elle commence sur une autre terre très
loin loin d'ici dans un endroit qui
s'appelle tous types à cames
dit comme ça ça alarmiste à ruban fait
sept villages de moustiques voilà là bas
les autochtones
s'exprimant tamouls et utilise aussi un
langage la drôle de langage auquel je ne
comprends rien il paraît que les
français ne sont pas bons chevaux langue
étrangère chauvine je ne voulais pas
faire mentir cet adage
donc je reste sourde à l'apprentissage
du tamoul est d'ailleurs à cet autre
nouveau langage mais un jour comme par
miracle
je fini par entendre ce nouveau langage
l'entendre avec tous ses codes
comment je rencontre alors à l'époque
une vieille femme une vieille âme a
comme on dit qui fabriquait des
éléphants en papier mâché et on le
traduit donc que cette femme me raconte
qu'elle health llc que j'ai du sang dit
si elle sait que j'ai des ancêtres qui
vivent ici
voilà et moi quand je regarde cette
vieille femme
je suis époustouflée j'en ai le souffle
coupé
pourquoi me direz-vous parce que j'ai
peur en même temps quand elle me parle
j'ai peur qu'elle me frôlent j'ai peur
qu'elle me touche et dans le même temps
je me dis
waouh elle a deviné j'habite à la little
aregno on ne sait pas que j'ai du sang
malbar mais elle elle a deviné qu'il y a
du sens dravidiens qui coule dans mes
veines
on dit que l'usld les yeux sont le
miroir de l'âme
j'en avais la preuve en face de moi je
regardais cette femme
cette femme qui a su toucher mon coeur
était une lépreuse et là d'un coup d'un
seul je m'autorise à guérir je
m'autorise à me pardonner des fautes à
comprendre que la beauté ne tient pas
qu'à des critères physiques et aussi je
m'autorise à mémé 90 60 90 j'ai parcouru
le monde et j'ai trouvé ce nouveau code
ce langage vous l'avez compris la beauté
universelle je les trouvais dans
d'autres pays que l'inde
je les trouvais dans les provinces de
l'afrique dans les contrées d'asie
je les trouvais en europe mais surtout
je les ai trouvés ici à l'île de la
réunion ici où tous les mondes se sont
donnés rendez-vous où toutes les beautés
se sont donné rendez-vous à l'île de la
réunion
alors voila moi de tout cet enseignement
j'ai tiré on va dire quelques lignes de
conduite que je souhaiterais partager
avec vous tout d'abord vous dire qu'on
les biens en 2015 c'est vers ça
aujourd'hui en 2015 j'ai la quarantaine
et vous avez compris qu enfin ce que
j'aime c'est moi ok bon j'aime aussi le
mât katia attractive mais le beurre se
bat comme le camembert gérard de mon
enfance à je peux j'ai perdu tous les
kilos superflus
ok voilà en tout cas moi ce que ça m'a
apporté c'est de voir différemment de
voir les femmes différemment deux
conseils
à partager avec vous le premier conseil
c'est de libérer le top model qui
sommeille en vous facile
ok à douter le top model attitude
comment facile
comment j'ai fait pour en arriver là je
me suis dit je vais changer d'état
d'esprit
le plus important c'est qu'aujourd'hui
j'habite dans ce corps là voilà le passé
est passé
le futur n'existe plus alors moi ce que
je vous propose c'est de vous aimer tels
que vous êtes au jour d'aujourd'hui est
de réveiller de libérer ce top model qui
sommeille encore en vous quand est ce
que pour la dernière fois vous avez
pensé à vous rien qu'à vous mesdames
faire quelque chose pour vous - c'est
maintenant sur ce podium
mais avant d'être sur ce podium j'ai
fait d'autres choses qui étaient folles
par exemple lorsque j'ai lu 40 ans je me
suis lancé un challenge un défi et je me
suis dit je vais faire je participe à un
concours
mieux un concours beauté j'ai 40 ans
j'ai tout ce qu'il faut je participe
résultat des courses voilà je suis
arrivée première dauphine de miss ronde
réunion en 2012 2013
moi je me suis dit c'est pas suffisant
il faut faire encore des choses plus
folles et donc je me suis dit je vais
créer un concours de beauté qui réunit
toutes les morphologies les femmes de
tout âge
voilà sans tenir compte excusez moi je
vous les présente là vous voyez monts
atlas de la beauté à travers mes titres
et de cette année je vous fait voyager à
travers l'inde et madagascar à travers
la france mais aussi
travers le maghreb c'est magnifique ça
c'est la beauté des femmes de l'île de
la réunion
ce que je chante train de vous dire ne
passait pas un casting pour aller faire
un concours beauté c'est pas ça que je
suis en train de vous dire que toutes
les femmes doivent libérer ce mannequin
là ce que je vous dis faites quelque
chose d'extraordinaire pour vous rien
que pour vous faites quelque chose qui
vous fasse vibrer fait quelque chose que
l'on pense incapable de faire ça c'est
important
ce qui est important aussi
ces deux vrais il faut oeuvrer pour que
toutes les femmes soient sur un pied
d'égalité que l'on fasse une taille 38
que l'on fasse une taille 60 aujourd'hui
quitter le mode loading c'est terminé
pour téléchargement c'est maintenant
qu'il faut passer à l'action
voilà le premier message que j'avais
envie de vous délivrer un deuxième
conseil que je pourrais vous donner
c'est d'observer cette personne
extraordinaire dans le miroir c'est à
dire vous les femmes ont l'art et la
manière de détailler toutes les autres
les petits détails les moindres défauts
ce qui est important aussi c'est de
pouvoir se regarder vraiment dans le
miroir un matin je me réveille chez
comme tout le monde je me trouve grosse
je me trouve moche je me trouve nul pour
achever tous et là j'entends une petite
voix lit donc toi tu ne pratique pas ce
que tu enseignes aux autres et là je me
suis dit c'est vrai il faut que moi
aussi je me regarde dans le miroir
il faut que moi aussi j'arrive à
traverser ce miroir pour me découvrir
derrière et enfin vivre en moi bon il
n'y a pas de méthode miracle mais j'ai
quelques petites astuces
tous les matins je me regarde dans le
miroir il me dit de belles choses voilà
je peux pas vous dire quoi ça se passe
introduit voix et puis ce que j'aime
faire aussi c'est accepter les critiques
les belles choses ok j'essaye de doser
le cursus de la vérité par rapport aux
feedbacks des gens entre la vérité et la
flatterie aussi ça c'est important aussi
de pouvoir accueillir ça voilà ce que je
fais ça c'était le deuxième conseil que
je pouvais partager avec vous dans le
message que je souhaite de faire passer
aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement en
tant que femme il faut te vrai pour
toutes les femmes
ce qui est important c'est d'arrêter de
se ghettoïser les roms par ici les mains
ces petites des grandes les blondes les
brunes intense que je peux continuer
comme ça à l'infini voilà donc mesdames
désolé messieurs un message pour les
dames aujourd'hui si vous faites partie
de ces femmes qui veulent cm qui veulent
se faire confiance qui veulent aller de
l'avant
je vous invite à la prendre à toutes les
petites filles de votre entourage
je vous dise juge pardon je vous invite
à apprendre à toutes ces petites filles
à s'affranchir des espoirs irréalistes
qui sont placés sur nous les femmes moi
j'ai réussi à le faire en tout cas
j'essaye de l'apprendre aux dames qui
font partie de mon association
j'essaye de leur apprendre la confiance
en soi l'estimé de soi
j'essaye de faire en sorte que ces
femmes qui se révéler pour qu'elles
puissent faire certain deuil aussi en
tout cas puisque qu'elle puisse devenir
sujet alors mesdames je vous le répète
apprenez à toutes les petites filles est
autour de vous à s'affranchir et dès le
plus jeune
des espoirs irréalistes placé sur nous
les femmes
je vous souhaite aussi de rencontrer la
l'épreuve qui changera votre regard et
peut-être cette petite fille qui vous
accompagnera comme moi qui vous dira des
choses lorsque vous vous regardez dans
le miroir je voudrais vous présenter
cette fillette
je voudrais vous présenter deux boules